humans and higher primates have even
number of fatty acid chain however odd
number of carbons are present in fatty
acids present in plants and marine
organisms now other than that especially
in case of ruminants which have a large
rumen
in that case fermentation of
carbohydrates forms a huge number of
three carbon propene you ate or
propanoic acid in this process now
today's topic is to understand how odd
chain or like odd number of carbon chain
fatty acids are oxidized we have already
looked at how beta oxidation takes place
for even carbon chain fatty acids now we
look at how odd carbon chain fatty acids
can be oxidized is the process similar
where their specific enzyme we are going
to look at all of these things in this
video so stay tuned till the end it's a
short video so this is 115 carbon or
chain fatty acid now first of all it
would be degraded or it would be
oxidized by simple beta oxidation of
fatty acid process six cycle of beta
oxidation would ultimately allow release
of 6 nadh 6 fadh2 as well as 6 acetyl co
a because each cycle come on Estelle
Kawai one in 88 and one fadh2 leaves
ultimately the carbon number is reduced
to 12 from 15 right and what we are left
with is a 3 carbon compound which is
known as propane oil Co a a 3 carbon
coenzyme a linked moiety now the problem
is the conventional enzymes how they can
degrade propanoic away that's the
important aspect now this particular
problem is circumvented in the fall
we propanoic Oh a gets converted to Dima
tile monoline cuy by the enzyme propene
Oh in Quaker boxiness it's a step up
reaction so from a three carbon a four
carbon intermediate is formed now with a
epimers reaction it would form elemental
Manimal cool a now it's just an isomer
that is formed because L forms are a bit
recognized by the body's enzyme from
Elma tile monaural Kawai ultimately
sucks in a way is produced
Sakina Kawai is for carbon as you can
see whereas propene alkaway was three
carbon so our problem was at the end
state if it's a three carbon then it's
very difficult to cleave it and release
the acetyl co way so the general
solution is perform a step up reaction
which is performed by these epimers and
carboxyl is enzymes and then break it
down equally to two molecule of acetyl
Kawai that's one of the way and the
other way is succinylcholine be directly
channeled into that Krebs cycle and that
is how it can be used to generate ATP so
this is the overview of fatty acid
oxidation in terms of origin fatty acid
going to be remembered now the goal of
fatty acid oxidation is to produce raw
material that can be used or that can be
channeled in Krebs cycle and ultimate
goal is to generate ATP in this
situation the sixteen Alcoa intermediate
even if it is not converted to acetyl co
a it can be directly channeled into the
TCA cycle and can be utilized to
generate ATP so the ultimate goal is
same the pathway by which we are
achieving these goals might be a bit
different but overall or gene number of
origin carbon number fatty acid and
eventual fatty acids are oxidized in
similar way but the key difference is at
the last step where the proper Alko is
converted to succinyl quire first and
then it is either channel into T si si
we are broken down into two molecules of
acetic away so this is all about origin
number of fatty acid oxidation I hope
you enjoyed this video this is a very
simple and very easy video so if you
liked this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you